Oh my god!
Hello everybody!
Happy Lunar New Year!
Woo!
Three streams and she still hasn't gamed yet for winning gamer of the year.
She still hasn't done any gaming.
We are on Day 3 of... Ok, not Day 3... This is like, Day 4?
Day 5?
Day 5.
I fucking lost count.
But three streams, still no gaming.
Still no gaming.
Don't worry!
That's gonna be next week.
That will be next week, guys.
I have my schedule all fully planned out.
We will be gaming for real next week.
But...
But yes, Happy Lunar New Year!
恭喜發財!大家帶來身體健康!
恭喜發財!
But yeah!
Oh my gosh, I swear to God.
Okay.
I feel like I've been like speedrunning VTuber prep in six days.
Like this, all of this would be like, you know, three to four months of prep time.
And I'm trying to get everything done in under a week.
Like I'm already uploading shorts.
I have a TikTok account now.
I got my old thumbnail maker, making thumbnails and stuff.
I'm... oh my God, like every day is just like, alright, gotta do...
Here's a list of things I can do this time.
Here's a list of things I can do on the other day.
And then today I like...
I like woke up.
I like woke up at like six in the morning.
I was like, alright, I can do this.
I can stay up all the way till my stream time.
And then I was doing work.
I was doing work all the way till like 12 p.m.
And then... and then I was like, I'm EP.
I was just like, oh no.
How am I tired already?
Oh, oh no.
This is not good.
So then... so then I was like, okay, okay.
I will take... I will take a one hour...
Sorry, like...
My... okay, I have my giant ass fucking tablet in front of me.
So like tracking wise is not... not so great right now.
My mouth be a little bit laggy today.
Okay.
So like I was like, okay, I'll take an one hour nap.
Well, guess who woke up at four?
4.30.
Also, yes.
I almost said the wrong name.
Memberships.
I was like hesitating because like it's... it's so ingrained.
Because I've been saying this other word for three years.
Almost three years.
I was like, wait, no, that's not what it's called now.
That is not what it's called now.
But yes, memberships are open now.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Yeah.
I've only... I grabbed that sub-batch of tomatoes from an artist.
I retweeted the artist.
I don't have it pulled up at the moment.
But...
But shout out to that artist for the tomato batch.
I have no idea.
All of these are like placeholders right now.
Because like I'm gonna be having a new mama not very soon.
So...
So like I don't even know what like my new skin suit's gonna look like.
You know, when I shed out this old skin suit and hop into the other one.
I have no idea.
Like there's no... no plan going on inside right now.
So like all we know is that deep within all of us there's a tomato.
And I was like, that's the safest thing.
Because... and that's why there's all like placeholder emotes as well.
Because I... I don't wanna like commission all these emotes.
And then like be like, okay, can you retry?
Can you retry all of these later?
Can you... I'll just be like, okay, um...
Can you like, um...
Redraw all of these for my new... new skin suit?
And then... so that would be very fucking awkward.
So I was like...
So like for now, we're just gonna have a bunch of placeholder emotes.
I'll just be like, I don't know, I'll just MS Paint some fucking placeholder emotes for all of us.
Um...
It might be just like all different pictures of like...
Doki Amber Doge there.
Uh... our resident dad.
So like...
I'll just be like Photoshop pictures of dad.
Also thank you all for the super chats!
Thank you for all the Akas and Magentas!
Thank you and all the other colors!
Um... Blue, I think, is one of them.
Um... but thank you everybody.
I really, really do appreciate it.
Thank you.
I hope you guys have a good Lunar New Year, guys.
Um... I feel a little bad because like I was supposed to have...
A... uh... you know, a traditional like, you know, Lunar New Year like lunch...
Uh... with my parents.
But then I passed out at 12!
So they're like, well...
I guess...
Will happen another day!
And I'm like, oops!
I'm sorry.
I was so fucking... I was so tired.
I didn't even... I just felt like I didn't like...
I didn't like...
I like slept in... I felt like I slept enough.
I did not stay up at all.
I like went to bed at like fucking 10 PM or some shit.
And it was just like... I'm... I'm just... I just died.
I'll just... I'll just fucking sleep, I guess.
And I'm like, why am I so fucking tired?
I'm still...
Oh my god!
I don't know.
I guess it's like I'm not used to streaming anymore.
I'm not... I... I'm just like not used to streaming.
So like my energy...
Look...
During that past month and a half...
Or like month...
I would just like play video games...
And stuff...
And I won't talk...
I really talk to people.
Like...
I...
Like even when I played games with my friends...
Like I didn't really talk a lot.
I would just be like...
Like...
I guess we would have like sort of a conversation.
But like I was mostly like...
Hibernation mode for most of it.
So like I was not ready to like talk.
And...
And like okay...
And also I was like...
You know...
Super fucking low energy when I'm talking to people.
Because I was just like...
Super low energy when I'm talking to people.
So I was just not ready.
I was not ready in life to like use all my energy here.
Um...
But yeah...
Anyway...
Today is the day...
We will name all of you.
And you will finally have a name.
And you will have a form.
So today is the day.
It will be the day...
You guys will finally not be nameless.
Uh...
No more arguing about what kind of name...
Oh I forgot to change the gifting fucking picture.
God damn...
Okay...
I knew I forgot to do something.
Um...
And we will...
You will finally have some fucking form to all of you.
But for now...
Not yet though.
Not yet.
We will get to that later.
Um...
We are not one name.
I am absolutely vetoing...
Is Freebirds.
Cause fuck that song.
It's a good song.
I will admit.
But fuck that song for demonetizing my...
I like how like...
Before I was like...
Oh...
I don't care if it demonetize...
It's not even monetize.
And then I got monetize.
And I'm like...
Oh...
That's awkward.
But it's like...
I'm not even monetize.
Yeah...
I don't have to worry.
I won't even...
I'm not even monetize.
Well...
Joke's on you dokey.
You got monetize right after.
Oh my god...
Okay.
You know like the sudden realization that I had.
Um...
I had like a sudden realization today because if you guys didn't know.
Uh...
Wonder Woman.
Wonderfest is going on right now!
And then some of you guys are like, wait, what's Wonderfest?
And well, Wonderfest is basically like the, you know, all the Nendoroids and the Good Smile Company, shit like that.
It's like they're showcasing all the new products that they're releasing.
And I... did you guys know that?
I did not know this.
But they're gonna be releasing Freddy Fazbear Nendoroid.
And then I realized, I was like, wait a minute, I can actually show that on stream!
I was like, oh my god!
Whatever I talk about...
I can actually show that on stream!
I was like, oh my god!
Whatever I talk about...
I can actually show that on stream!
I can show the picture on stream!
It blew my mind!
I was like, I don't have to link the images anymore!
Or be like, alright, just Google it.
I can actually show it on stream!
Oh my god!
Anyway...
Oh my god, I need to show you guys this.
I knew I downloaded it.
I was like, where the fuck did I download this picture of Freddy?
Freddy Fazbear Nendoroid.
I was like, where is it?
Oh my god, look at this.
Look... oh my god!
I can't believe there's a Freddy... holy shit!
I can't believe there's a Freddy Faz...
Don't worry, this is transformative work right now.
So like, I can't put a picture of Freddy Fazbear next to me.
I was like... it just makes me wonder, like...
What are the interchangeable faceplates to?
Like, wait!
Does that mean I can put like...
You can put like a head of like...
You can put like the head of a different Nendoroid.
On top of Freddy Fazbear's head.
Like... you can put Freddy Fazbear's head on different Nendoroids!
Oh my gosh.
The possibilities are endless.
I was so surprised.
I did not realize.
I can't believe Freddy Fazbear has a fucking Nendoroid.
But yet he is not on Fortnite.
I'm so mad.
We can do the...
We can do the bite of 87!
Oh my god.
I can't believe it though.
Where the fuck is my Freddy Fazbear on Fortnite?
Like, they have a Nendoroid but not like a fucking Freddy Fazbear on fucking Fortnite.
Just... it pisses me off.
It pisses me off.
But yes, thank you everyone again for the memberships.
I really do appreciate it.
For those who are wondering, who are new here that don't know...
Usually what entails in a membership...
Basically, membership streams will include like...
You know, like gaming with me.
So like I would open like servers and stuff where you guys can like play video games with me.
Like for example, I'm planning on...
For next week, we're going to be doing Garfield Kart next week.
So in the member stream.
And also like there will be like other types of gaming servers that I might host in the future.
Like maybe a custom PAL World server or like custom Minecraft server.
Usually Minecraft server, I hope when I do get it established, I want to make that super long term.
Other servers tend to be short term because like in the past, I've done like one month of Rust.
Like a Rust server for members, like for one month and stuff like that.
So it really...
And then other things would be like, you know, like sometimes members get to decide like the schedule.
Or like they get to decide...
They get to vote on the schedule and stuff of what to do.
Also, I will be including like, you know, exclusive wallpapers that will be released in members.
And like, you know, like we used to do this thing called...
Okay, I used to call it like average movie watch alongs.
But now, now that I'm in indie, I can finally call it shitty...
Shitty slash bad movies watch alongs.
Now I can call them shit.
So now...
It will be like...
Sorry, bad movie...
Okay, shitty slash bad movies watch alongs in members.
So we can...
We usually do that as well.
So...
We don't have to be like quote unquote average.
Now I can actually be like, no, they're actually terrible movies.
They're actually terrible movies.
So...
So we can do like terrible like bad movie watch alongs.
And that's really it.
Like members is just like...
It's just a lot of like...
I think like the most fun part is like the bad movie watch alongs.
And also the like...
The gaming streams.
Like if I do like streams where I play video games.
With you guys.
It's usually reserved in members.
Unless it's like something like a...
Like an Apex server where there's like a lot of people or something like that.
Like...
Like I think like the one time I made it public gaming was...
Was Apex or something.
I think that was the one time.
I don't remember.
So...
And there were a lot of streams blurred together.
But yeah.
Anyway, oh my gosh.
Little life update.
I contacted...
Um...
A Twitch staff today.
And I was so...
I was very like...
What's so weird?
I was very grateful.
Because...
The Twitch staff still loves me.
And he was like...
Oh yeah.
Yeah Doki.
If you still want to do like Twitch rivals.
Or like anything like that.
Like we will still support you.
And we will still invite you to Twitch rivals and stuff.
And like...
I think they thought that I signed like an exclusive...
Contract with YouTube.
Because they were like...
We thought you moved to YouTube forever.
I was like...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's the same thing.
I like do YouTube and Twitch sometimes.
I'm just Doki now.
I'm just...
I was like...
No, no, no, no.
I'm just Doki.
That's the only thing different.
I'm just Doki now.
So yeah.
And then like the Twitch staff was like...
Yeah, yeah.
We have like this event actually coming up.
Obviously I can't say what the fuck the event is.
And they're like...
Yeah, we can like get you in on this next Twitch rivals.
I'm like...
Yay!
Yippee!
Thank you!
I'm like...
Thank you so much!
I can still be like...
I don't even go here.
And I'm participating.
I can still say that!
Yay!
So that was really nice.
I was like...
Oh my god.
Thank fucking god.
I can still do...
I can still do Twitch rivals.
Oh my god.
But yeah, like every day is just another thing to do on my checklist of like...
All the other...
Of like...
Like just be like...
Alright.
So usually a VTuber would have...
You know...
Would...
It would take a VTuber like maybe like...
Six plus months to like get this done.
In their career.
And then I'm like...
Alright.
Gotta finish this in one day.
Gotta get all these editors down in one day.
Make a server for them.
So they can work together on clipping my stuff for my channel.
Alright.
Gotta contact like...
Like overlay people.
Shit like that.
Boom.
One day done.
Alright.
Set up the store.
Boom.
One day done.
Contacting artists to make my channel.
Make future merch.
Boom.
Another day gone.
Holy fuck.
Speaking of speedrunning.
I have to...
I have to make a new...
God damn it!
You think they'll let me change?
Guys.
Can you...
Can you like name change your speedrun?
Your speedrun.com username?
Guys.
Can you like name change your speedrun?
These are still my records!
Those are still my records!
I swear.
I am...
You know what?
I'll...
I'll check that out later.
I'm gonna see if I can name change my speedrun.com.
speedrun.com username.
For those who don't know...
In the past...
In the past, I've submitted speedruns on speedrun.com.
They're not necessarily speedruns, but like...
They're so ridiculous that...
They still accept my runs.
So it'll be like something like, you know...
If there's like 30 submitted runs and then like the 29th run would be like some like one hour or something something to complete and then the 30th run will be me.
And it'll be like five hours and then the mods there would be like, you know what?
It's still... she submitted it.
She's... she's still the 30th person to submit it.
So like I guess we accept it.
I guess we accept... except for one.
There was only one time I got fucking rejected and it was for fucking Peppa Pig because...
Out of all the games I've submitted Peppa Pig was the only time someone... one of the mods rejected it because the mod was like, this is serious.
Of course the Peppa Pig mods were the ones that told me that.
They told me this is serious.
This is clearly not a speed run.
And I was just like why Peppa Pig.
Why Peppa Pig of all the games, Why was it Peppa Pig?
I was like I would, I was like, I know I'm like, you know what reasonable that Reasonable that like they would reject me but the fact that the other moderators were like, hee hee ha ha like this anime girl.
Let this girl- ah- This anime girl will make a fool of herself.
But the Peppa Pig speedrunning community is very serious indeed.
So don't submit joke runs in the Peppa Pig community.
They do not take that kindly.
They are not here to fuck around.
It's a very serious speedrunning community.
Um... but...
I still couldn't believe that they rejected me there.
But yeah...
Yep.
Don't worry.
I, Doki, will continue on the tradition of submitting runs for fucking stupid games.
I saw someone chat was like, Peppa Pig isn't just a game, Doki.
You don't understand.
There are like 0.001 like, uh...
There's like...
buttons.
Button teleporting...
Okay guys, you can tell I...
Sorry, I'm like a professional speedrunner.
I do have like records on speedrun.com.
But like, uh...
I like invent my own terms, okay?
That's what professionals do.
We don't use the established terms that you normies out there use.
We have our own specific personalized terms.
Um... that only people within the speedrun community uses.
So...
Hahahaha...
Oh my god.
Uh...
But that reminds me that I do have...
I should...
I should make a new speedrun.com account.
Okay, guys.
Alright, so...
Um... later on, I'll be showing you guys...
Uh... the Lunar New Year merch.
That'll be releasing...
Not today, because that'll be fucking crazy.
Hahaha...
Me...
Like...
I already have a lot of things to do.
So...
It will not be released today.
Even though...
You know, it would be the perfect time to release it.
But like...
We...
Me...
Mr. Man...
Little Man...
Have a lot of work to do with our current orders.
And our current...
And our...
Um...
Uh...
Our current...
Like...
Workload that we have to do.
So they'll be released...
Much later.
But like...
Oh my gosh.
So there was this one artist...
I...
Uh...
Contacted.
How much merch are we buying?
Double merch?
Look guys.
Rebuilding a shrine is a lot of work.
Also I don't mind if you guys like...
Uh...
Merch shrines and stuff.
Because you know...
It was still me.
And this current time is still me inside.
So...
Uh...
No matter what form I take...
We all know...
Within...
Inside me...
Was still a tomato.
So like...
Like...
You might not have seen a tomato...
Inside me.
The other...
The other one.
But there was a tomato inside...
Inside of it.
So...
In the end...
If you want...
Merch forms...
Merch shrines...
That's cool by me.
Yeah.
It's cool by me.
Like in the end...
There was always a tomato.
Um...
But yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Speaking of...
I did not realize...
My tomato mama...
Was the person...
That made the shrimp Miku.
Because that shit like...
I saw that when...
That comic went viral.
And I was like...
What the...
Who...
Wait...
Who's this?
Was this the person?
Because like...
I...
I remember...
I remember the day...
I asked them...
To make me a tome...
Make my...
True form...
My tomato form.
And it was like...
Um...
It was like...
On Tumblr...
Like...
I never...
I never realized what their Twitter was.
I like asked on Tumblr.
So I was just like...
Oh my god.
It's the shrimp Miku artist.
So who...
Those who don't know who the shrimp Miku artist was...
Um...
The shrimp Miku artist...
Was the one that did the shrimp Miku.
I know.
It's...
It's so...
The...
The shrimp cooking Miku.
Um...
That was you know like the Hatsune Miku contest that they...
That they like host every winter.
So like...
Um...
Like their design went viral.
And then like everybody really liked it.
Because the shrimp Miku was holding a knife.
Like you know...
They were like...
No.
Miku does not hold knives.
I think...
I don't know.
It's like the funniest reasons why I never went to the finals.
Because they're like...
No.
No knives for Miku.
It's like how they're like...
Mickey Mouse must never hold a knife.
Mickey Mouse must always be PG.
Mickey Mouse must never have a purse.
I know like you can be like the...
The recent Mickey cartoons with the really funky art style.
That show was really good.
That was a really good cartoon show.
But like...
If you guys didn't know...
Like the...
The handling of Mickey Mouse was...
Oh my god!
I can literally pick up...
Put a picture of...
Of Mickey Mouse on my screen if I wanted to.
Also the fact that it's public domain anyway.
So like the...
The...
Steamboat Willy Mickey.
But anyway.
But like...
Like the...
The thing about Mickey Mouse is that on the guidelines about Mickey...
Is that he must not have a personality.
Or like his personality must be generic as fuck.
So that anyone can like...
So that...
So that like...
He doesn't...
Like he doesn't have...
Any ideals that you can imprint on him.
So he has to be like...
Super generic with like...
So that he does not offend anybody.
So that's why Mickey cannot hold it.
Mickey cannot do any of those bad things.
Mickey is a self-insert.
I mean even if it was a self-insert.
If it was a self-insert...
At least he would have a personality.
But Mickey Mouse is meant to have no personality.
Or like the most generic fucking personality out there.
Um...
Because they don't wanna like...
Cause like he's now just a mascot of like Disney.
He's not like an actual like...
He's not real.
I mean he...
I'm sorry.
He was never real.
But like...
He...
He's just like the face of the company type deal.
Like a little puppet for everybody.
He's not like an actual...
Like...
Per...
Like a actual personality anymore.
Um...
He's a JRPG protagonist.
That...
Oh my god.
Oh yeah.
A little fun fact.
Also another fucking fun fact.
You know like those...
That time when I like...
All I did to pass the time was either play video games.
He's real to me.
Hehehehehe.
What's it like to have the most fucking generic character as your friend?
Your favorite Disney character?
Hehehehehe.
I swear.
Even though like Mickey is like the face of Disney.
He's never the most...
He's never the favorite.
He's just like...
He's never the fucking favorite.
If you ask people like...
Who's your favorite Disney character?
I...
More people would say Donald Duck than fucking Mickey.
Because like at least Donald has an actual personality and shit.
Like at least like people like...
Fucking relates...
Relates to him.
Because you're like...
Wow!
My god!
He's like...
He's like somebody that has a personality.
Uh...
No one will ever really say Mickey Mouse.
Unless you wanna buy like his Mickey ears that are like...
$30 over price.
Hehehehehe.
I can say all that.
I mean I feel like I used to say this stuff too.
But like I wouldn't be as harsh.
But now I'm like...
Well I can sort of be harsher now.
Unless!
Disney!
If you wanna sponsor me...
Um...
I didn't mean all that.
I swear.
I swear to god.
I still love Disney.
Just not...
Mickey's just not my thing.
I still love Disney.
Just not Mickey.
Mickey is just not my favorite.
I think my favorite Disney character is...
Uhhhh...
I think it is sort of...
Donald was my favorite.
I'm not sure if current Disney is still Donald.
You know what?
Cause I haven't...
I think we all know...
Disney movies...
So far...
Haven't been doing so hot.
Like it hasn't been like doing that well lately.
Including Pixar.
Because like...
The thing about Disney...
I like how this is like Happy Lunar New Year.
But I'm just going off these like...
Random fucking tangents that are unrelated to Lunar New Year.
Um...
But like...
Recently so far...
Uh...
A lot of like movies from Disney and Pixar...
Are like...
And all the franchises that Disney owns...
Which is a lot of them...
Have been like set to like...
Made so much money...
And they're so scared to fail now...
That they go through the same...
Fucking formula.
Over and over and over again.
And they're too scared...
Of making a new IP...
Because they don't want to fail even more.
Because the last time they tried to make new IPs...
Now like the last five years...
Is the fact that like...
Um...
It didn't do so well.
So now...
They're banking on nostalgia factor.
And making five to ten...
Plus sequels now.
Like what do they say?
These are like this year...
They're gonna be working on Toy Story...
Like a sequel for Toy Story...
For Cars...
For like...
There's like so many...
Fuck Toy Story...
Why the fuck does Toy Story need another sequel?
It ended perfectly.
Also please...
Tom Hanks and the other guy...
I'm sorry.
But like...
Not gonna lie...
The other guy that plays Buzz Lightyear...
He's really only...
He's really...
His only like work right now is Toy Story.
Uh...
Tim Allen!
You guys can be like...
I know you guys are like...
But Doki!
Tim Allen has done this and this...
Yes in the 90's.
I don't know if you guys know...
But like...
I feel like...
If you ask like...
A zoomer...
Right now...
Who the fuck is Tim Allen?
They would be like...
What?
Who is Tim Allen?
I don't think any zoomer right now...
Would know who Tim Allen is.
Just know it was the 2010's.
Um...
Yeah anyway...
Michael Theodore Mouse?
Is it real?
I know like Mickey was like based off of something...
Walt Disney wanted to like...
I don't remember.
I just know like...
It was something related to Walt Disney.
Somebody related to Walt Disney.
But yeah... Oh yeah.
The Wish.
Yeah.
You know like...
The music...
Okay I feel like everybody talked about the music of the Wish.
But like...
The composers they got to write the Wish...
Like the music wise...
Were like...
Top 100 like pop song music.
And like...
That's fine and all.
But like Disney music is not meant to be a pop song.
It's not.
Because like...
Also like pop songs are like...
Usually about like...
You know...
Like romance and like love and like...
Girl crushes or boy crush...
Mostly girl crushes.
They would be like...
I mean girls crushing on boys for like tweens and stuff.
And...
And like...
So they weren't writing it as if the song has a story.
That builds up to the...
Because like they are trying to write a top hit song.
Per song.
So like none of the songs connected to each other.
Because normally pop songs...
You know...
They don't connect...
Like if you have an album full of pop songs from an artist.
They don't connect to one another.
They like...
There's no story behind it.
Each song itself is a story.
But not like...
Like a story from one story to another story.
That leads up and connects to each other.
It's literally like...
Here's it's own story.
That doesn't fucking make sense.
Because it's supposed to...
They want to have like a trendy song.
And then here's another story.
That doesn't fucking make sense.
Because they wanted to try and get like a top 10 billboard pop song.
And then...
And then she becomes a fucking fairy godmother.
Alright spoiler alert.
Because I know for sure none of you guys are going to watch Wish anyway.
Neither am I.
I just watched someone else.
So like this information you're getting from me.
Is basically...
I got it from another video.
So now I'm regurg...
You're basically getting a name.
Researched that by going to 3Ders.
So like this information is like...
Forth hand.
You're getting...
Forth hand information.
So...
Because I'm not fucking paying money to watch Wish.
But basically...
And I don't think any of you guys are going to watch Wish in the end.
Unless like... I don't know.
I don't know.
You're like a Disney completionist or something.
But basically...
Wish ends it.
Because it's supposed to be a celebration of like...
100 years of Disney.
So like it's not meant to be...
It doesn't have it's own identity.
It's mostly...
It's like a nostalgia factor.
Based off of like it's own IP.
So you're trying to instill nostalgia.
Also...
Fuck the live action Pinocchio.
Because they did that too.
I watched it with my friend.
Like they had a scene where it's like...
Look at all these Disney IPs that we own.
That we show.
With the clocks.
And I was like why the fuck is this all Disney?
They're like...
You want to see how much IPs we own?
And it's like...
And you see like...
Like hundreds of like...
Like miniature Disney IPs.
In like form of clocks and stuff.
So they keep doing that.
So...
Um...
Anyway...
Sorry I got a little pissed off.
Because I can't believe I watched live action Pinocchio.
But like...
It was...
I watched it for 15 to 20 minutes.
And it was 15 to 20 minutes too fucking long.
Anyway...
At the end of Wish.
They were like...
Like the main character...
Becomes the fairy...
The...
What is it?
Cinderella's godmother or something?
They implied that she becomes...
The godmother...
The fairy godmother.
In Cinderella.
And I was like...
What the fuck?
And then they imply that all these people...
Like the main antagonist...
Becomes the mirror in Snow White.
And I'm like...
Why?
What the...
Why did they retcon their entire Disney line up?
It doesn't make sense.
They retconned the entire...
Past of Disney to be like...
Wish was the OG.
It was the original.
So yeah.
That's why I'm like...
I don't know if you guys noticed this.
But I'm definitely...
Oh yeah.
They made it cinematic.
As if we don't have...
Enough cinematic universes...
In the fucking world.
They basically made the...
Disney animation cinematic universe.
I was like...
Really?
So anyway...
I saved you guys like...
I don't know how long Wish is.
But I saved you guys enough time...
To never watch Wish.
Because it is absolutely...
It sounds terrible.
And like...
I don't want to put myself through watching it.
Because I feel like I already know...
It sounds terrible.
And I listen to the songs and the lyrics make...
No fucking sense.
The DCAU.
But like...
Like okay.
If you ever listen...
I listen to one Wish song.
And the lyrics don't make fucking sense.
Like not even like grammar wise.
Because it's like...
It's like a very deep lyric.
But there was like one part where they're like...
It's like they use R.
Instead of like...
I don't know... is or something.
And it did not make fucking sense.
I was like...
What the fuck is going on?
Excuse me.
Um...
But yes.
Okay we might watch Wish's members maybe.
So we can actually like figure out...
What the fuck is going on.
Like...
It's...
And then like Pix...
I don't even remember the last Pixar movie.
Like...
It's so soulless now.
That's why I don't...
Like a lot...
For those who don't know...
A lot of the Pixar staff and stuff got restructured.
And they left to Sony Animation.
Which is why Sony Animation is very...
Um...
Sony Animation is like incredibly...
Uh... Like... It's like doing...
Well... Because...
Sony and Dreamworks.
Because a lot of old Pixar...
Okay Elemental.
Not gonna lie.
Um...
Elemental...
Despite how fucked up the...
Marketing was...
It was actually a good movie.
Like...
For some fucking reason...
They fucked up the...
Marketing of Elemental.
Because for some reason...
They tried to like...
Advertise the wrong thing.
For Elemental.
So like a lot of people...
Were like criticizing it.
And stuff.
And then when I finally watched it...
I watched it on a plane.
By the way.
Most movies now...
I just watch it on planes.
Because like... I can't...
I don't have the patience to like...
Sit...
Sit down on my PC.
Because I don't go to the theaters.
To stream a movie.
Because I'm always like...
Working and stuff.
But like...
I actually cried in like...
Some parts.
But like...
They had like a...
A fake movie... For those who don't know...
Elemental...
Had a fake movie reaction...
Scene...
As a marketing thing.
Because...
There was this rock boy...
Or this like... Was it this grass boy...
And like they tried to make him like...
The funniest character ever.
Like he's like... Tried to make him a...
Thief.
Even though he was in the film.
For like... Two minutes.
This little boy...
Was in the...
Claude!
Yeah this little boy...
Was in the film...
For like two to five...
Minutes.
But they tried to...
Make him like the funniest shit...
Ever for marketing.
Because like they...
The official Disney...
Like TikTok account or something...
The Elemental TikTok account...
Posted a fake...
Movie reaction...
To when Claude came on...
Screen... Sorry...
Came on screen...
And it's like... You know like the...
Big Bang Theory laughs and stuff...
They inserted like... Big Bang Theory...
Laugh tracks and stuff...
And be like...
And like...
Whenever Claude came on...
And like... Oh my Claude!
And I'm like...
And then move... And it's like...
Movie theater...
And then like quote on quote...
Movie theater as like a...
Fake reaction marketing...
And...
And like... They pushed...
Him so fucking hard...
And I was like... Why the fuck...
Is he... Why?
But then like the movie itself wasn't...
Bad... It was pretty...
Decent... It was really good...
But like they made everybody...
Be like... Whoa don't watch...
Elemental it sounds awful...
Because of the Claude marketing...
Laugh tracks and stuff...
Like yeah...
It's so...
It was like the weirdest...
Shit ever... Anyway...
As much as like...
I shit on... New Disney...
Old Disney was pretty...
Great... I still like Disney...
Just not really... New Disney...
New Disney is just...
Too fucking...
Um... Formulaic now...
Um... I always felt it... I knew it was like...
Getting super formulaic from...
I don't like Marvel movies...
This is my... Uh... Controversial take...
Of... Controversial take...
Number 530...
Today...
Laugh tracks and stuff...
I find...
I never really liked...
The Marvel Universe...
Because it was... It was just...
I like... You know... You can be like...
No... No... But what about this movie...
It's just...
If you look into the...
Plotline... Like the...
Story structure... Of the Marvel Universe...
It's...
It's the same thing... It's like...
It's... It's literally the...
Same story...
Spanned into like...
20 different movies...
It's...
It's so predictable...
It's so...
It's so... I will admit...
Like the first... You know...
The first 2 or 3 of the Marvel movies...
Other than Guardians of the Galaxy...
But that is because... James Gunn...
Is a very talented director...
But then...
But then James Gunn became formulaic too...
They like... Try to follow the...
James Gunn formula...
Cause they're like...
Cause they're like... Oh my god...
Guardians of the Galaxy did so well...
Because it never felt like a Marvel movie...
It didn't feel like a fucking...
Marvel movie...
So then they were like... Oh my god...
We need to copy this now...
And every fucking movie started becoming...
Like Guardians of the Galaxy...
And it's like they add humor...
When it wasn't supposed to be meant to be humor...
And it's like...
That is my rant of the day...
That is...
That is my rant...
Oh yeah also like...
Tidy or whatever was his name...
He's also a good director too...
He's also like...
A...
A really decent director...
But then like... Disney tried to fucking...
It's like... I don't... They're like... You did so well...
Let's copy that... And then it's like... No...
The thing that they did so well...
Was what made it super unique...
If you keep fucking copying it...
It's not gonna be unique anymore...
Like that's the thing... If you keep copying it...
It's not gonna be...
Good... Because it's the same thing...
...
Oh my god...
Oh my god... Anyway...
I'm speaking my... I'm speaking my truth...
Right now...
I had like one month build up...
Of things I wanted to complain about...
And I'm getting out...
On Lunar New Year by the way...
But Doki...
Are we supposed to have a name and a form...
Guys let me speak my truth...
Then I'll name you guys...
Then I will name all you guys...
I need to speak my truth...
Right now...
Um...
If it sells... It sells...
Yeah... But like... It's so...
I'm trying to remember... There was this director...
That was like... I fucking hate...
Superhero movies...
I forgot which director said that...
But like... There was a director...
Anyway... If Marvel wants...
To sponsor me... I love...
Marvel movies... By the way...
Just saying...
Disregard everything I said earlier...
I was... It was just a joke...
I love Marvel movies...
Anyway... Um... Um...
There was like this one director...
Cause like he said like...
There's like no more soul...
It's all about making money...
At that point... Um...
And that's why this director was like...
I hate superhero movies... Because I...
They don't care about filmmaking anymore...
It's just all about...
Movies that make money...
So like... And which I agree... I agree...
Every superhero movie is all about...
Like trying to... Trying to...
Not be like good... Story wise...
But like... Good enough...
To make millions of dollars...
Like...
Which is...
Um...
Um... Which I...
I 100% agree... I'm not even like a big...
Movie person... Um...
But like... I... I just...
I just... Don't really enjoy...
Enjoy superhero movies...
Except if it's DC animated...
Cause the funny thing about animated...
D... DC movies...
Is that they don't fucking care...
About... About being...
Like... Morally correct...
Like...
Like... But...
They don't care about being morally correct...
They actually go to places...
With their story...
And... For the DC animated...
Um...
Movies... They actually like...
Care to like... Do stuff with their stories...
And like... Surprise you...
With like... What they...
Wanna talk about... Um...
Comics wise...
I will admit like... Recent DC...
Like... Even like...
Comic wise... Recent DC comics...
Fucking... Not great... Uh...
The old ones were... Like...
The ones in like 10 years ago...
Were so much better versus recent...
Uh... Uh...
But yeah... That's... My truth of the day...
I... Sorry... I went through...
A long tangent regarding...
That...
You know what's cool though?
I recently found out that...
Santa Claus is like an X-Men...
In... In...
Yeah... Like...
I was like... In like...
Marvel Universe... Like...
In the... Did you guys know that?
Like... I saw like a YouTube short...
Being like... Santa Claus is considered a...
Mutant... And... And that's why...
He can live for... He can teleport...
To like... Houses all the time...
And stuff like that... Yeah... He's like...
Yeah... I was like... What the fuck?
They made Santa Claus an...
X-Men?
I was like... Oh my god...
What the... What the...
Fuck... Um...
I mean... That makes sense...
Also... Speaking of superheroes...
I heard like the Suicide Squad...
Um... Very...
Poor timing with the name word that I just...
Said out loud...
I just...
Said it out loud... I was like... Oh yeah...
That's what they're called...
Anyway... I heard the new game...
For that...
Was... Um...
Was like...
Because they're built off of like the...
Arkham Asylum... The Arkham...
Asylum games... And like...
Apparently I heard...
That like...
If it wasn't in the same universe...
As Arkham Asylum...
It would have been like...
An okay game... The fact that it was...
Like... The fact that...
It built off of like...
Batman Arkham Asylum...
And was also like...
Kevin... Kevin Conroy?
That's his name?
The voice actor of Batman?
That's been a voice actor of Batman?
For like... Um...
For like...
A long, long, long, long time...
And that was like his last...
Fucking role...
And they did him incredibly dirty...
For his last role...
To be fair... They did the entire Justice League...
Very dirty...
And like...
And like... I read...
That like... If it wasn't connected...
To Arkham Asylum...
It would...
It would have been like...
As bad as...
And so the fact that they fucked over Kevin Conroy...
Over there... It would have been as bad...
As of the reception...
And I heard they might be...
Deleting Steam reviews... So I don't know...
I don't know which is true...
I don't know...
Who it is...
Oh...
They lied about it being his last role?
That's fucked up...
That's actually fucked up...
They like... They knew...
They knew exactly... Okay, let's spoil it...
They kill off Batman...
In like the middle of the game...
They kill him off...
And it was like the...
It was like done very terribly...
It was done incredibly...
Terribly how they kill him off...
It's like... It's really weird...
Um...
So like...
So like... So then they were like...
This is gonna be his last role...
And they knew... Alright...
They knew how fucked up...
They're gonna kill him off...
And then like... Why the fuck would they advertise it...
As his last role... Knowing that like...
In hindsight... I guess like in hindsight...
They didn't know how bad the reception was...
But like... I feel like if I was in the marketing room...
And I was like... We're gonna kill off Kevin Conroy...
And we're gonna tell everybody...
That's his last role...
People are gonna fucking love that...
Like...
Why the... Why the fuck...
Who thought people would love that...
Like...
Like... People are gonna...
Fucking love that shit...
Like...
Um...
But like... Anyway...
Uh... What was I gonna say?
Oh yeah...
Uh... That's what I was like...
I heard they're deleting...
Negative Steam reviews too...
But like... I don't know if that's true...
I don't know if that's possible...
Cause like... If you could delete negative Steam reviews...
I feel like...
Knowing... I feel like Overwatch 2...
Would have done that a lot earlier...
I was like...
Like if that was possible...
I feel like... A lot...
A lot of games would have done it...
It is...
It is... Wow...
Honestly... You should... You might as well...
Own it... Like... If you're gonna...
Have... Like... Cause then like...
At least people would like... Because like...
You can get a...
Refund in two hours...
Like... Why...
Why are you tricking people to buy your game...
When you can get a refund in two hours...
Like...
Wait... They did?
Oh my... I love Overwatch by the way...
But I... Like... Any big...
The thing is... Any big...
Multiplayer...
Game... Will have negative...
Reviews... On Steam...
Cause you cannot make...
Anyone happy... Like...
It's... It is... 100%...
If you look up any big...
Multiplayer game...
With like...
With like a ranked competitive system...
Nobody is...
Fucking happy... And...
Somebody will complain...
It's... Like... Like...
I swear people will be like... No... You can't say...
No... That's not true...
I love... Blah... Blah... Blah...
If that game is on Steam...
There is 100%...
That the reviews would either be like...
Negative... Or...
Mix... Because people would be...
Like... Okay...
Team Fortress 2 never had a ranked system...
It never had...
It never had an actual...
Ranked system... It had like...
Fun moments... Funny... Ha... Ha...
Things to do there... But it never...
Really had a ranked system...
And... When Team Fortress 2...
Came on Steam... People...
Were a lot nicer back then...
Ha... Ha... Ha...
People...
People were...
When... People were a lot...
Nicer... When it came to...
Like... Online reviews...
And also they had hats...
Nobody would complain about a game...
That has hats... Like...
Ha... Ha... Ha...
Ha... Ha...
Like... Apex have...
Oh... No... When Apex...
First came on Steam...
Like... Those reviews were...
Not great... Like...
I... I... No... No... No...
I remember... Cause I remember...
Having forced to...
Download... Uh...
Apex... On Steam...
And it was like... Extremely...
Negative... The reviews...
Cause everyone...
That got fucked over in rank...
Is right there... Ready to complain about it...
On Steam... Cause if you give people...
A chance to complain... I.E.
Me... A platform... Right now...
Cause we literally spent an hour complaining...
About everything...
Ha... Ha... Ha... Ha...
We will fucking...
Complain... Like... We will...
We will complain...
Um...
But yes... Well... Anyway...
Welcome to the Tomato Farm everybody...
Thank you... Thank you for...
Joining the membership... I really appreciate...
You guys... Welcome to the farm... And thank you...
Everybody for the Akasupas... I really...
I have so many Super Chats...
To catch up on... I'm so sorry...
I... I'm so sorry if I didn't...
Read your... I haven't read a single...
Super Chat... You know what?
The next person...
That gets Super Chats...
You won the Gotcha... I'm gonna read off...
Your fucking Super Chat... Right here...
Right now...
Give me Titanfall 3... I am so sorry...
To tell you... But I feel like...
At this point... It's easier...
To get a million dollars...
Than it is to get... To get Titanfall 3...
Like...
It's easier to win a lottery...
Than the other one... Because like...
I... As long as...
Apex still makes money... Like...
I'm sorry... Also... Oh!
Thank you for the Super Chat...
Thank you... Thank you... Hi...
Too bad for the guy below him...
He did not win...
The Gotcha...
Fastest fingers in the West...
Oh my god... Jenny!
Thank you for the Akasupa... Thank you... Thank you...
Alright... This person also won the Gotcha...
Thank you guys... I really appreciate it...
Um...
But yes... Unless...
You buy EA...
I apologize...
But I really don't think we're ever getting Titanfall 3...
Because Apex just makes...
Way too much money at that point...
Like...
It just...
As long as it keeps making money...
As long as you keep buying those skins...
I don't know...
I don't know... Um...
Because I was a fool...
I was a fool too...
I used to buy Heirlooms back then...
Um...
And then like... I realized like...
The Heirlooms were so distracting...
I... I... I for me...
Like... Because I play Rank a lot...
I don't like equipping Heirlooms...
Because like... It's just so...
Distracting for me... And they're so...
Fucking... Big...
But... Apex...
If you wanna make a...
Doki Heirloom themed...
I would equip... I would buy all your Heirlooms...
I would just give back your money...
Hahahaha...
Alright... Anyway...
Anyway...
Before I give you guys a name...
And a form...
I wanna show you guys the Lunar New Year Merch...
That will be released TM soon...
I don't know when we're gonna be putting it...
Up on the store...
But like... Um...
I really really wanna show you guys...
What it is...
But anyway... So...
One of the artists...
The one of the artists I reached out to...
Like... They didn't know who I was...
Before... Cause they're like... You know...
Cause they're like... Who the fuck...
Who the fuck...
Is Doki...
Um... And then they're like...
Wait!
I used to watch your streams...
And they're like... Oh please come to Bilibili...
Whenever you have a chance to...
Um... And stuff...
And they like... Gave... Drew like...
They drew like freebies for all of us too...
So like... I'm definitely gonna be using...
Cause they drew like a free gift...
For all of us... Uh...
For like merch and stuff...
Afterwards... Cause they're like... Wait!
I love watching you...
Um... But like...
Let me show you... This is the same artist that did...
Uh... The aqua...
This is the artist that did the acrylic stands...
Uh...
Let me show you...
It's so cute... I was like... Oh my...
God!
It's so cute!
And they did like extra stuff...
For it too!
Cause I was like...
You don't have to!
But they like added the...
Extra like... Extra stand...
With my name on it and everything...
So... Look at it!
Ah!
Look at the...
They didn't have to but they like added the extra...
Like stand for like...
The name too... It's so cute!
This would be the...
Lunar New Year acrylic stand...
Like... Oh my God!
Hello!
Doki here!
Uh... So yes thank you!
Shoutout to this artist!
Um...
And also they did... Uh...
This is gonna be...
A... Pillow...
Like you know there's like mini pillows...
And stuff... So this is gonna be like...
The pillow...
Uh... Artwork... And...
Then we also have...
So this is a freebie they drew...
Which I'll definitely throw it in...
Um... And for those who wanna buy...
Bundles... So they drew these...
As freebies... Uh...
So like there's like the button designs...
Um... And also like some...
Stickers here... And everything...
And it's so cute!
I know!
They drew that!
For free!
I was like oh my God thank you!
I was so sweet!
I was like...
Oh my God this artist is so...
Um... So sweet...
And everything... I thought it was...
Incredibly cute!
Anyway!
Also there's the red pocket...
Envelope... What's their name?
It is...
Let me... I'm gonna butcher their name...
Let me grab it real quick...
It is... Uh...
Asuroku?
I'm gonna show the...
Um...
I'm gonna show...
The... I'm gonna link...
Link it real quick... But this is the...
This is their... Their...
Twitter... Give me a sec...
I can't find my cursor...
But this is their Twitter...
For those who wanna check the artist out...
Oh my God it's so cute!
Also the red pocket envelope...
So... Uh...
There's like three designs... And I'm really...
Like... I was...
Blown away because I gave them...
Artistic freedom for...
Both... Uh...
For... Sorry I can't read...
Sorry... Only my manager knows how to read...
Sorry...
Only my manager knows how to read...
Um...
But like...
This is like the...
The red pocket envelopes too...
So like... Oh my gosh...
The outfit is so cute!
It's so cute!
But there's like three designs...
There's this one as well...
And then there is...
The last design is...
Uh...
This is the last design...
And like... Oh my God...
They were so fast...
I really did not expect...
Them to finish...
The artwork...
Uh... Like...
In time for the...
I really...
So like... Do you see the gold?
The ones that have gold...
Will have like gold foil print on it...
So it's gonna be like the... You know like the reflective...
Gold... In the Lunar New Year...
Stuff... Like...
It is gonna have like the gold reflection...
To it too... I think like...
I've always loved...
Uh... Designing...
Merch... Or like just...
Um... Like... Have ideas...
For like merch and stuff... So I'm...
I'm going wild with these...
Um... I guess like...
Also this is the artist for the...
Red pocket envelopes and stuff... So...
So it's...
Super exciting to be able to like...
Um... I guess like...
Have all these ideas and stuff...
And being able to...
Being able to like...
Put it out there... And...
Uh... What's super exciting...
Is that... I'll...
I always love spoiling...
Like... My next...
Like idea... But like...
The next merch drop that I'm planning on doing...
After... This one won't be like...
Super soon... By the way...
It just coincided...
With each other... Cause like...
Lunar New Year and...
Uh... You know like the merch that...
The debut merch I had made like...
Three... Four years ago...
The four year old merch...
That's my debut merch...
Um... Yes...
The red pocket envelopes will be sold as a set...
And there will be...
Five envelopes...
Per...
Design... Uh... So it will be like...
Five envelopes per design...
Um... And...
Uh... But yeah... And what was I gonna say?
Fuck...
Guys... Oh yeah!
Sneak peek!
But the one thing I'm currently...
Working on now... Um...
Is a...
Uh... I contacted an artist...
To do like... One singular...
You know like those like...
Uh... Like a...
One singular keycap design...
So it's not a keyboard set...
Or a keycap set...
But it's like one keycap...
Um... That has like...
Uh... Where...
Where it's like laser engraved...
So that light will... It'll be like my face...
And then like light can shine...
Through it... Past the line...
Alright... So stuff like that...
Um... So yeah...
Artisan keycap... It'll be one artisan keycap...
Design that I'm working on...
Right now... Um... Trying to find a...
Manufacturer... Also like all these...
Stuff... All these merch...
I personally find the...
Manufacturers... And...
I personally reach out to... Like...
Research like manufacturers and stuff...
Or like samples and everything...
And also... Um... I...
Reach out to artists that... That would...
I think would make these... Like...
I reach out to artists that I think...
Would do it justice...
Type deal... But yeah... I'm doing the next merch...
Drop... Drop... Not anytime...
Soon by the way... Will be an...
Artisan keycap... Which is something I've always...
Wanted to get... That made...
Um... And...
I'm super... Super duper excited...
And everything... So yeah...
Just something to look forward to... Very slowly...
And honestly like doing this...
Is also like... Stuff I want...
Of myself... So...
Hahahaha...
You know...
I like... I wanna look...
At myself more... So then I was like...
These are things I want...
Personally... So like...
So I... These are...
Um... But usually... You can...
You have to buy... Like...
You have to buy a minimum amount of stock...
So like... It's a good benefit...
Because I can...
Hahahaha...
I can... Acquire...
These items...
Um... And not have to worry...
About the extra stock...
Like... I can...
Hahahaha... Because when you get things...
Manufactured... Usually...
It's a minimum amount that...
You need to order... Because I remember...
When I was trying to order... Like...
I was talking to manufacturers...
For like... Red pocket envelopes...
They were like... Um...
Yeah... But you have... I was like...
Can you like... Make like...
A hundred... And they were like...
Minimum order... A thousand...
Hahahaha...
I was like... Oh...
Thank god... Thank god...
I have an audience now...
So I can get away with that...
I was like... They're like... Minimum order...
One thousand...
I'm like... What the fuck?
Wow... Oh god...
That's a lot...
Um...
Um... So yeah... I was just like...
Oh thank fucking god...
At least I can sell my extra stock...
That I'm not gonna keep...
Hahahaha...
No... It's not like... It's not about like...
I can afford it... It's more like...
If I didn't... You know... If I didn't...
Have a fan base... Or if I didn't...
Have an audience... I was like...
What the fuck am I gonna do...
With nine hundred and fifty of them...
Like... What am I...
What am I... What am I gonna do...
With all of these...
Like... What?
And I'm like...
Oh thank god... People will actually buy it...
This time... I'm like... Oh thank god...
Cause I'm not like a licensed...
Character... You know...
It's not like I'm fucking Sonic or something...
Sonic the Hedgehog...
Where like... They're like... I know Sonic the Hedgehog...
I'm gonna buy it... I'm just...
Me... So I was just like...
Oh my god...
Like... I think... I'm so happy...
You guys love me enough...
To buy...
Buy the extra stock...
That I got...
Why you need... So I can use it...
And look at my...
I can use it and look at myself...
Cause I love myself...
A little bit more now...
Uh...
Rainbow...
Thank you for the magenta soup...
Thank you...
You have so many options... Awesome things planned...
Tons of stuff for us to look forward to...
Thank you... Thank you for the magenta soup...
I mean... I also not just like...
Merch of... Like you know...
Merch I get of myself...
Like... Made by me... But also like...
I'm super excited to like...
Work with other distributors... You know...
Like being like... Like other companies...
That wanna make merch of me and stuff...
And that would be super exciting...
You know... The one thing...
I'm gonna tweet... Actually I'm gonna tweet that out later...
I'm gonna tweet... Wait where's my...
I'm gonna tweet that out... But...
I'm gonna add Funko Pop and...
Alright guys...
My dream collab...
Would be a Funko Pop...
And an android... But like...
I feel like it's more... It's easier...
Maybe... To get a Funko Pop...
Than it is to get a nendoroid...
Okay... Hear me out...
Hear me out...
Why I would wanna get a Funko Pop...
You have to think of it...
Business wise...
Just think of...
Think about it... Business wise...
Why...
A Funko Pop would be so funny...
But basically...
The thing about...
Funko Pop collectors...
Is that...
They...
Will fucking buy...
Every single Funko Pop...
To complete their collection...
It doesn't matter...
If they don't know who that person is...
They are...
Insane collectors...
That will collect...
Every fucking Funko Pop...
Out there...
So then... They're gonna see a Doki Funko Pop...
And then they'll be like...
Who the fuck is Doki Bird?
I must have her in my collection...
And then...
Normies...
My OBS disconnected...
Holy shit...
While I was talking about...
Funko Pop...
Anyway...
As I was saying...
You have to understand...
Like... Normies...
Would be like... Would see that...
At like... Fucking GameStop...
Because who the fuck buys games...
At GameStop...
Like...
Every fucking...
And conventions...
There's always...
10 to 20...
Sellers...
Selling Funko Pops...
And only Funko Pops...
So...
A Doki Funko Pop...
Would be everywhere...
It'll be mainstream...
It'll be a hot topic...
Imagine going to a hot topic store...
And seeing a Doki Funko Pop...
Like... You barely find anime stores...
Because like... People just order online...
People don't really order online...
For Funko Pops...
They fucking go to Hot Topic...
Or Walmart...
I could be in Walmart...
I could be...
I could be in fucking Walmart...
A Walmart exclusive...
Just like think about...
The Doki flocked version...
I could have like multiple versions...
Of myself...
In Funko Pop...
And like...
It could be like the Doki Metallic...
Walmart exclusive...
Just... Business wise...
It is the smartest thing I can ever do...
Like...
Think about it...
No... The Doki...
The original Doki...
Would be... Oh my god...
Thank you for the 50 conditions...
Thank you...
Thank you so much...
Like... I kept different exclusives...
In different stores...
So like... The Doki Metallic version...
Will be in Spencer's...
The Doki flocked version...
Will be at Toys R Us...
Only in Canada...
Because Toys R Us is apparently...
Bankrupt in America...
I...
The fucking...
The...
The 2 feet tall...
Doki Funko Pop...
Exclusive...
At Target...
Just imagine the possibility...
And then they can make different outfits...
Normies will have to collect me...
Because they need to collect...
All the fucking Funko Pops in the world...
So like...
To look at me...
And then maybe they'll look me up...
You know...
Maybe I'm not just a Funko Pop in their collection...
Maybe they'll just look me up as well...
And then they become fans of me...
Um...
And that is why...
Funko Pop...
Is my dream collaboration...
And also Nendoroids...
Because like...
That's obviously a better thing...
But...
And the thing is...
Because Nendoroids are very picky on who they pick...
To make into a figure...
Funko Pop...
They love making Funko Pops...
So there is a higher chance...
There is a...
Higher chance...
Of me...
Being picked up by Funko Pop...
Than it is to be picked up...
By Nendoroids...
Because they love making...
They love...
The things...
So...
That's my TED Talk...
That is my...
That is my TED Talk...
For Funko Pop of the day...
Anyway...
I'm going to tweet at Funko Pop real quick...
Can you give me some...
Let me...
Let me add Funko Pop...
Real quick...
Guys...
Guys this is important...
I need to add Funko Pop...
Alright...
Collab...
Let me...
DMs...
Are open...
Alright...
There you go...
Anyway...
Alright...
Here we go...
Sorry...
I tweeted at Funko Pop...
I hope that maybe they'll...
Maybe they'll see this and be like...
Who the fuck is she?
Oh my god...
Anyway...
Mika thank you for the 50 gift ships...
Thank you...
And you know they love to do anime stuff...
I'll be like...
Come on...
I could be your first Vtuber...
Wait no...
I'm not even their first Vtuber...
Is it like...
I got a Funko Pop...
I don't even know...
They have so many Funko Pops...
That I don't even know...
If they already made a Funko Pop...
For Vtuber...
There's been so many...
Hehehehe...
But if they haven't...
Come on...
I'm right here...
I could...
Come on...
I could be their first Vtuber...
Funko Pop...
Come on...
It'll be so funny...
Hehehehe...
It'll be...
It'll be so funny...
Hehehehe...
Anyway...
That is why...
Funko Pop is my dream collab...
Anyway...
I was supposed to name you guys...
I was supposed to...
Hehehehe...
Sorry...
I was...
Oh wait I should follow...
I'm gonna follow them too...
You know I should...
Let me follow Funko Pop...
Real quick as well...
Oh my god I forgot!
I need to follow Peppa Pig...
I forgot to follow Peppa Pig...
My Oshii...
On this account...
I almost forgot to follow my Oshii...
Miss Peppa Pig...
On this Twitter account as well...
Alright nice...
I got done with what I wanted to...
Umm...
I got...
I got done with what I wanted to...
With what I wanted to talk about...
Anyway!
Guys!
It is time to...
Name you guys...
For once...
It is finally...
It is finally time to fucking name you guys...
Okay...
Alright!
So someone apparently listed all the names...
Suggestions...
Shout out to Nari...
For listing out...
All the names to use...
To suggest...
That you guys all done...
It is like three fucking documents...
Ha ha ha...
Trauma right there...
So...
Suspects...
Nesties...
Whatever that was...
Hoodlums...
Robins...
Nightwings...
Chirpsters...
Penu...
Penguins...
Tomotories...
Oh my god...
Hello Tomotories...
No I can't...
Chick...
Boons...
Dookies...
Burracos...
Chickadee...
Why is Tomotory...
Tomotory but like...
Not plural...
Like what?
I like how...
They put Tomotory twice...
But like one has an S on the end...
So you know it's multiple people...
Um...
Aviators...
Do-Dokies...
Side chicks...
Boobies...
Sly beaks...
Quack-seeders...
Dough-matos...
Canaries...
Pip-cheeps...
Little birdies...
Two caniers...
Peck-pockets...
Lock-peck...
Do-ka-bows...
Fowl-players...
Swallow-beets...
Wing-beats...
Chick-peas...
Crusaders...
Hello Crusaders...
No... Oh that's... It was almost good...
It doesn't roll off your tongue as good as it...
As I thought...
Uh...
Dream-birds... Nightmares...
Average chirp and joy...
Claw-birds... Sun-birds...
Tor-you...
Sun-risers...
Peek-peeks...
Beacons... Gale-talons...
Gale-talons...
Talonites... Talgales...
Jallows again...
Someone really likes to swallow...
Plunder-birds...
Sky-lark...
Burbons...
Flock-faces...
HAL-birds...
Nighthawks...
Scuffy's... Tree-birds...
Bird-scribers...
Bird-scribers is so clever...
Hello bird scribers...
It sounds so fucking dumb...
Crookies...
Gamefowl, Knifefowl, Peckling, Tailors, Sparrows...
What?
Why do we have Sparrows but in four different forms?
Like... in this list?
Birdbrains, Spectres, Dohchicks, Victories, Convicts, Falons, Cartel, Tori...
Tori Matto... Tori Matto... Tori Matto's...
Pancakes, Dorkies, Lunatics, and Motherflock.
Jesus Christ.
There's so many.
Oh my god.
Alright.
So which one fucking... like hit that note for you guys the most chat?
Out of all of those names...
Which one was like, yeah!
Yeah!
This is it.
Okay, I see a lot of like...
I see a... no.
Freebirds have been officially vetoed.
We are never going to be Freebirds.
Out of pure fucking spite, we are never gonna be Freebirds.
I will not have you guys be Freebirds.
That song is fucking cursed now.
That song.
What I was thinking of was like Tori Bird.
So you guys would be called Bird Bird.
Hello, my Tori Birds.
My little Bird Bird.
Okay, I see a lot of...
We're not gonna be...
We are not going to be fucking Nesticles.
Alright.
No, I will never let you guys...
be Nesticles or Freebirds.
I see a lot of suspects.
Hello suspects.
Welcome to the stream suspects.
Alright, let's see.
Bird Bird is pretty cute.
I like Tori Birds.
Hello Tori Birb.
Tori Birbs.
Or Tori Birbs with a B at the end.
So like Bird Birb.
Alright, do you guys like Tori...
Okay, we're not...
We're gonna have a poll.
But like if I put Tori Bird...
Tori Bird or Tori Birbs...
in the poll...
Would you prefer...
Tori Bird or Tori Birbs?
Or Tori Birb?
Do you want to be Bird Birb...
or Bird Bird?
Is either Bird Birb or Bird Bird?
Tori Birbs.
Hello my Tori Birbs.
Tori Birbs, what are you doing?
Birbs!
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, I have my poll then.
Alright, it's either...
Okay.
Let's see.
I want to know what the other options were.
There's like suspects...
and then nesties.
That's like fucking nestle or some shit.
I see a lot of suspects.
I see a lot of...
Uh...
Tori Birds...
and...
What is the third option, guys?
Third...
We'll have four...
Four choices for the polls.
What is the third option you guys want to add in?
Tomotori?
Hello Tomotori.
No, I'm vetoing Tomotori.
I like two syllables.
Alright, guys.
I'm going to be real with you.
Two syllables.
Oh, damn it.
I feel like two syllables is like the perfect amount of syllables when it comes to like names.
Like Doki.
You know?
And the other one.
Like two syllables is like the best.
Nesties?
Oh my god.
We are not going to be nest...
Okay.
Guys.
Alright.
I'm going to put the poll up.
I mean, how do I put the poll up?
It's been a while.
Okay.
Poll.
Alright.
Add option.
Okay.
Here we go.
Naming.
Okay.
I might like start moving weirdly because I don't know where my bindings are.
Naming ceremony.
Okay.
The first one is...
I'm going to be...
Suspects.
Right?
Suspects with a K.
Ends with a K.
I think.
Oh my god.
The chat is so laggy when it comes to typing.
There's so many.
Thank you everybody for watching little old me.
Oh my god.
Thank you everyone.
Let's see.
Okay.
Liberties.
Look guys.
As much as I love to be like America.
I'm not American.
Robins.
Hello Robins.
My little Robin.
God.
That name is just like Batman.
I'm just...
Then it just goes into Batman and Robin.
Doki and Robin.
Okay.
Tori Bird.
So you guys can be like Bird Bird.
Tori Birb.
Tori Birbs.
Okay.
Let's see.
It should be a capital T.
All right.
Nest...
We're not going to be Nesticles.
I am...
I have like unlimited veto power.
And definitely one of my unlimited veto power is fucking Nesticles.
And also Free Bird.
Oh my god.
Uh...
Toma Tori.
Hello Tomatori's Hooters.
We're not...
I am...
I know that put Hooters in the poll as a fucking joke.
I'm not gonna call you guys my little hooters.
I am not gonna call you guys my little hooters because that has a different implication.
Funko Pop will never sponsor me if I call you guys hooters.
Think of the Funko Pop, guys.
Think of the Funko Pop.
Let's see...
Eagles, Nightwing... today is such a sad day.
Just because you don't get Nesticles or Hooters doesn't mean it's a sad day, guys.
There are other options here.
There are other options.
Okay, I see a lot of Tomotories.
Okay, I'll put that in.
Tomotory, Tomotory...
And then...
For the surprise fourth option...
I thought about it a very long time.
And to be fair...
This is the surprise option.
I thought about it for a very long time.
But I realized...
Wait a minute...
You can't come...
Copyright the word...
Dragoons.
Because it's a real word.
And...
If Dragoons win...
It's like crocodiles and alligators.
You know?
A crocodile was still called a crocodile...
Millions of years ago.
It was still called a crocodile...
But it just evolved.
You know?
It evolved.
So all I'm saying is that...
What I'm thinking of when it comes to Dragoons...
It's like a military unit.
And honestly, you know...
Obviously...
Why did I think about Dragoons?
Because I was like...
Oh my god!
It's like Starcraft.
You know?
Starcraft is my favorite game.
Anyway...
Obviously, it's a surprise fourth option.
It's like a surprise fourth option.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, here's the pull.
Here's the pull.
Nesticles is officially out and running.
Nesticles is officially...
Oh my god!
It's so laggy in chat.
I felt like it took an entire minute for this to load.
nesticles presidente el tiempo Juanita Salom très So...
So, here we go.
Fight, fight, fight for your name!
Fight for your name!
No, Nesticles, my beloved!
Look, you guys had like...
Oh my god!
Oh my god, you guys like fought so hard.
For those that wanted to be Nesticles, look guys...
Nesticles, you guys could have pretended to be Nesticles when you guys had no name, okay?
That's not my fault.
You had the freedom to be a Nesticle for like six days now, okay?
You guys all had the freedom to be a Nesticle for six days!
Those might have been the best six days of your life.
But now it's time to be renamed, okay?
Now...
Now it's time to be renamed.
Everyone had six days to...
Had six days to be whatever the fuck they are.
Oh my god.
I love...
I love how...
Like, I could have just said Dragoons in the very beginning.
But I made you guys...
That's typical Doki version.
I made you guys fight amongst yourselves for like six plus days, deciding a new fan name for yourself.
And then I'm like, J.K.
Dragoons is an actual word.
I strung you along for six days, yelling at each other, trying to figure out what your new name was going to be.
But don't worry guys.
Dragoons can evolve.
Like all dinosaurs...
All dinosaurs eventually evolved into birds.
Which is, you know...
It was...
It was like...
It was like we wrote three pages of names.
I guess we're done.
Somebody was like...
It was like, Doki, we worked so hard coming up with all these names.
We worked...
We worked so hard coming up with all of these names, Doki.
I can't believe it.
Alright, I'll do one more poll for you guys.
I'll do one more poll for you guys.
Because obviously, we'll have the two finalists fight each other.
For like, the true winner.
The true winner.
We'll have...
Naming ceremony.
Naming...
Ceremony.
Alright.
Dragoons...
Versus...
Suspects.
We just all evolved, you know?
We just...
We're just evolving.
The closest ancestor to dinos...
If you guys didn't know...
Are birds.
It's just...
We're just evolving, everyone.
We're just evolving.
Enough years have passed by for evolution to take in its effect.
Alright, here we go.
Give us a fact that I refuse to vote.
I will only vote if it's nesticles.
Well then, he's gotta...
He's gotta be...
Well...
Thank god for that.
Thank god we vetoed nesticles.
Oh, this is really close though.
This is actually really, really close.
When you close your eyes...
Does it always feel like nothing has changed?
Oh my god.
That's actually a lot closer.
A lot closer than I expected.
I know that you guys would be like...
But Doki, didn't you say you don't wanna have goon as the last part?
Because of...
Because of what they did to goons?
Dragoons would be like my only exception, to be fair.
Like, I don't think I could ever adopt a new name with goon in it.
But...
I just have a particular attachment to dragoons.
That it would be my only exception...
If it wins the poll.
If we win...
If it wins...
The rule says you cannot vote...
Because then it would be confusing!
That's the rule!
It would be way too confusing.
If there's two names.
I guess like for suspects...
Because I still want...
Four different forms.
So like...
Chonky Peck.
Chonky Sus.
Oh my god.
How would it be...
How do we say it?
Would it be Chonky Sus?
Or Chonky Specks?
Chonky Pecks?
Chonky Sus Specks?
Chonky Speck?
Chonky Specks?
Long Specks?
Long Sus?
Uhh...
Egg Specks?
It was this one design that...
Like some people were submitting designs.
And there was one design that I would really like that gave me some ideas.
And like why I was like thinking maybe we...
If Dragoons wins.
Um...
There's like this idea on how to like this idea.
Wanted to do.
Uh...аки Susqu.
Oh god...
You two both almost gave up my idea.
They don't JUST ASrese程 Waiting here.
Yes Rick thing
I'm trying to sing like, chonky peck, chonky sus, long peck.
Sorry, long peck sounds so fucking weird.
Because then I can think about it as like pecks, you know?
And then...
Then long peck, egg peck.
That's a word.
Is it like, people are now voting more for dragoons?
Because like, no, actually, I don't think I want to be called that.
I don't like it.
Sus goons, please, I want to be a dragoonier.
Where is... there's no free bird!
They lost their voting power after the first stream.
Doki bros, because every time we see...
Alright.
Oh my god, okay, so like...
I forgot to tell you guys this story.
But like, when I was playing...
Apex, so like, obviously I've been playing Apex a lot during that one month.
But like, one of them was...
Hahaha!
I'm so...
So...
Okay.
Oh, wait, never mind.
I can't say it.
God, sorry, I'm gonna like...
You're just gonna be like...
You're gonna get blue balled for the rest of the stream.
Because I'll never say what it was.
Sorry.
Hahaha!
I guess you'll never know the story.
You'll never know.
Something funny happened.
But you'll never know.
You'll never know the story.
Very unfortunate.
Alright.
I'm gonna give you guys one more minute.
Suspects, rise up if you wanna defeat the old.
And bring in a new generation.
It's like a dynasty.
You wanna overthrow.
Overthrow the old.
And bring in your new dynasty.
Suspects.
Are you strong enough, suspects?
To kick those boomers out?
Hahaha!
Suspects installed the bots.
New name for the new year.
Suspects rallied the undecided voters.
This is it.
Rally the undecided voters.
Hahaha!
If you want to win.
You have to rally the undecided voters.
Rally up!
And kick those old boomers out of office!
They would have... they would have lost in Nesticle.
You know, honestly like 100% if Nesticles was in there, I would 100% agree that...
that they would have won over Dragoons.
Come on, suspects!
You're young!
There's more of you!
You really got to let a bunch of old Dragoons out there take away what you believe in?
Come on!
How long are you gonna make us dance?
I just want to see if I can get 50-50 right now.
Come on, Dragoons!
Hold the line!
Don't let those youngins take our office!
Dragoons will be in office forever!
Suspects!
Rally up the other ones!
Rally the Nesticles to vote for you!
Oh my god, wait a minute.
Suspects are actually winning.
Holy fuck.
I didn't expect that to happen.
Guys, come on!
It's new year, new us!
If Doki can change their names...
We can too!
Doki... Dragoons... Really?
You're gonna let a bunch of like... young... young birds tell you what to do?
Come on!
You're a military unit!
You're really gonna let birds tell you what to do?
They're like, Connie!
We fucking eat birds!
Like...
New era suspects, come on!
Dragoons, today we reclaim our legacy!
If it's 50-50, we should pick Nesticles.
Alright, Nesticles is like the third party that has like only one person in office.
And even then, they can't really do much.
It's like... it's like 50... it's like...
Suspects versus Dragoons have like majority of the seats.
And then, Nesticles is that one guy.
Like the one... the one person in there that has power there.
Where their votes don't really count, but they're there!
They're in the office!
Push the 50-50.
Alright, Suspects.
I feel like I gave you guys...
Like... so much time to like... fight for what you put in.
And what you believe in.
But like...
Just like the real world, Boomers are always in charge.
So...
Suspects.
I feel like this is a harsh lesson of reality.
Of what the real world is like.
Where even though you have a cool new idea.
No matter what, in the end, the Boomers always win.
Because they refuse to die.
They'll be 90 years old.
And still in office.
And you can't do a damn thing about it.
So like...
As a young one.
As a little baby Suspects.
Watching an anime girl...
Show you the harsh reality.
And give you a simulation...
Of what that was like in the real world.
But now...
I reject change.
Thank you for the magenta soupa, Alan.
Thank you, thank you.
Like I say.
Alan is one of those...
Old goons.
He- He- He- He- You have to overthrow goons like that.
To get what you want.
Can we be suspects on April Fools?
Anyway... I'm sorry Suspex.
I gave you enough time to try and overthrow the old power.
But it seems like... it seems like the dragoons have evolved and kept... they're birds now.
There was a ten minute... I gave you guys ten minutes to fight for what you believe in.
And if you can't fucking fight for what you believe in within ten minutes of me giving you extra time to rally for it...
That's not on me.
That's just reality at that point.
Because in the real world, you have like almost a whole year to figure this shit out.
Not even a year, but you have multiple years to try and not let the old people win.
But in the end, not even just in like... in like... I guess like policies wise...
It's also like business wise too.
That's why you need to overthrow any CEO that's eight years old.
I'm talking about you.
CEO's name I don't remember.
Who's literally like fucking deleting movies for tax reasons.
Like what the fuck?
Okay, I know I talked about it yesterday.
But I have to talk about this again.
Like this guy, the CEO of like Warner Brothers.
Fucking deleted Wile E.
Coyote for a tax break.
And like other studios offered money.
And he's like, no, not enough.
Like what the fuck?
Like other studios are like, hey, I'm willing to buy your movie.
And they're like, no.
But it's basically like Coyote versus Acme.
And it's like this like mockumentary...
I think it's like a mockumentary style thing.
About Wile E.
Coyote trying to like in a court case against Acme Inc.
And like apparently the test screenings was actually really nice.
Really did really well received.
But like Warner Brothers CEO was like, we need more tax breaks because we're losing money.
And I'm just like...
What?
Yeah, those poor actors and those poor...
Those poor actors and like the production company.
They leaked the production company video of...
The production company video.
They like leaked the...
I guess like the cast party.
Like the behind the scenes of everything.
So you could even see like all the set designs.
And everything that was built.
All the stuff that was built for it.
And it looks like so much time and effort was built.
Anyway.
Sorry, I need to get that out of my chest.
Because I still can't believe they fucking shelved that movie.
Anyway.
Happy Lunar New Year.
Congratulations.
You've been named.
It's sad that suspects couldn't win the poll.
Put another poll.
Hooters versus...
I like how someone was like...
Hooters versus dragoons.
We will win.
Nesticles poll.
No.
Alright, I'll humor you guys.
I'll humor you guys.
Alright?
Alright.
Just for those who are like...
No, you don't understand.
Nesticles can...
Nesticles will beat dragoons.
We got you!
Alright.
Anyway.
It's time to give you guys a form.
So, there was this one artist from Thin.
Like, her name is...
Their name is...
...thinen.
And Thin...
They've like...
They've done this concept.
Okay, fuck you guys.
We're not gonna be...
So like, they did this concept design for you guys.
And that's what got me an idea of maybe perhaps we stay with dragoons.
Also, Joe, thank you for the 50 conditions!
Thank you!
Oh shit, what the fuck?
Okay.
There was like something that came on my screen.
And I thought it was showing up on stream as well, like my drawing program.
But then I was like, oh no, that's just like on the... that was just covering up my YouTube previews.
So it looks like it was on screen.
So let me show you guys this picture.
So I really liked this concept.
But obviously I'm gonna tweak it a little bit.
To make it work more.
But I'll show you guys here, yeah.
Alright, so...
Now we're here.
I love how it says like sub gold top donation.
I... Sorry, that was like Twitch meta.
And all my overlays I'm using are like old Twitch stuff.
So that's why it's like... what the fuck?
Why is there that stuff?
So, wait, let me show you guys.
So this is the reason why I thought about it.
Thought about... cause I really... I liked how... oops, sorry.
I liked how it was like...
It felt like the dragoon was evolving.
You know?
This... it looked like an evolution of a dragoon.
We're not gonna be called nesticas!
I was humoring you!
So, I... it's gonna... I wanna take like certain...
We're not gonna have cheek dots too.
We're not... we're not gonna have cheek dots!
I told you, we're not devolving!
We're evolving, okay?
We are...
We are evolving, okay guys?
So... so that's why I really enjoyed this concept.
And that's what got me thinking.
Because obviously, uh, dinosaurs evolved into birds.
So I liked how like, it's like a semi-evolution of... of like a dinosaur.
And I thought that was a really neat concept.
And then the fact that it has like... you know...
I guess like, what do you say?
The long... long goon?
The chonky goon?
And then I don't know which one's the chonky goon.
Not to be fair.
I don't...
I hate my little nest... nesticles.
Doki, you don't understand!
It rolls off your tongue!
I hate my little nesticles!
We're not going to be nesticles!
Thank you for the akasupa, Pancho.
Thank you, thank you.
I love democracy.
Alright.
Alright, so that's what I was thinking.
So like...
I was thinking of like...
I'm trying to like think of like the default base design.
Because I do think like...
That's...
Really cute.
Like the...
Uh...
I like how there was somebody that was like...
And I like how this is like...
You know how it was like this?
The...
But then it went up?
Because I don't know your fucking head evolved...
Fucking weirdly, I guess.
So like...
Instead of the side...
It went up.
So it stood...
Fucking went up.
Um...
What?
Thank you for the akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Satisfying this.
What did you say?
I supan my first ever supa to you a while back.
This is my first akasupa ever!
What a perfect day to give you a red rectangle with my...
Thank you, thank you for the akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
I...
This was not enough, guys.
It was not enough.
This was not official.
I said I will humor you guys.
I did say it was out of humor.
And I like how, you know, there's like still horns and stuff too.
But I don't know if like...
I'm trying to figure out like...
The proportion wise.
We're like a normal goon.
So I don't know if I should like...
You guys should have a body.
Or you guys just be all head.
Like I can't tell.
I can't tell if I want you guys to be all head.
Or...
Or like...
Or like have a body.
Because then what would the chonky goon look like?
What would the chonky goon look like if it's like...
If you guys...
If it's...
If it's all head.
Or the...
One year Neste goes...
No!
Because then...
It would be confusing if I changed the fan name a year after all head.
No way.
So you want to make it look like...
The thing is I was like wondering...
How to like distinguish you guys too.
You know?
So like there's the tail.
Like that and then...
And then...
There.
It's just...
You guys look like a fucking tomato.
Oh my god.
I don't know if you guys should have wings.
I don't know...
I don't know if you guys should have wings or not.
Looking pretty nesticle here.
I don't know guys.
I don't know if you guys deserve wings.
You guys haven't...
I feel like you guys just haven't evolved into wings yet.
Like...
I want to edit this a little bit though.
Okay, so if it has wings, you guys would look like...
You guys would look like...
Like basically like a raptor.
Like the original concept was like that.
But I feel like it would be cuter if you just have like...
Like if it's just a potato arms.
It'll look very stupid.
We need small wings.
So you want to look like this?
I don't think I want like the bows and stuff though.
I was like thinking like...
You'll still keep number...
I...
I've always liked that concept but I don't think we can do that.
You know what I mean?
Let us fly.
Okay, we'll let you fly.
And then...
Alright, so it'll be like...
Boom, boom, boom.
I feel like...
I don't know.
I'm just like thinking like...
Uh...
Like what is a way to...
What is like a way to...
differentiate all of you?
We obviously can't put a number anymore.
Arms and wings?
Guys, now you're demanding.
We should be flightless?
Okay, alright.
We're gonna have a poll.
No either wings or no wings.
Either...
Either you guys have no wings and you're like this.
Or...
Oh my god.
Wings or no wings?
Wings, arms or no arms?
The arms would be like that.
But then wings...
I feel like arms would be better.
Arms would be so funny.
I like how somebody was like...
I don't know who it was but like...
Please, I don't wanna be a bird.
So this is like the next...
Next best thing!
We're not gonna have cheek dots.
I know you guys really want...
I mean...
It does look really cute though.
The...
Boneless or boneless?
Okay, wait.
Give me a sec.
Let me check this out real fast.
Let me see what it looks like.
Let me see what it looks like without cheek dots.
Let's see.
I don't know.
I'm trying to think right now.
I'm trying to think.
I feel like...
Give us those we deserve.
I'm trying to think.
I'm trying to think if you guys deserve to have cheek dots or not.
Bone in or bone out.
No cheek dots.
Dot cheeks will rise again.
I feel like no cheek dots is better.
Just cause like...
Just cause I think it's cuter without it.
I feel like...
I feel like it's just cuter without it though.
Pull please.
Okay.
Maybe...
Cheek dots for me.
I don't want to be cute.
I...
Sorry.
That one guy does not want cheek dots.
He does not want to be cute, guys.
He doesn't want to be cute.
It's like...
A real man doesn't have...
Cheek dots.
Okay.
Anyway.
I want to be cute though.
I want to be cute.
Fuck that guy.
I think like merchant...
Like plush wise.
I think it's easier to...
I think it's...
It's better...
For them to not have cheek dots.
Because like plush wise.
I personally think plush wise.
No cheek dots.
Look better.
Versus like...
When...
You look at stuff like...
In real life.
Because it's hard to make cheek dots work.
On a plush.
No!
Give it back!
Alright.
And to make things easier.
Oh.
Okay.
Me.
I hope...
I hope it's okay if I edit the artwork a little bit.
Just to help me get an idea.
Alright.
Let's see.
And to help it...
Sinking.
Maybe like...
Like this.
I think maybe like a belly.
A white belly.
You want a white belly or nah?
Let's see.
A little white belly.
Maybe look like this.
For the white belly.
Like that?
It's not just all yellow.
At that point.
Like there's more colors to it.
Hat?
No!
What the fuck?
This is my hat.
Find your own hat.
What the fuck?
Find your own hat!
You're not gonna have hats!
You're like, team fortress gives you hats.
Yeah!
Then fucking go Oshi team fortress too!
Okay.
Alright.
I have an idea.
This is a default form.
Right here.
This is gonna be default guy.
And then...
Long...
Longoon would be like...
Yeah.
This is Longoon.
Just like that.
Longoon has evolved to...
He's like a little...
How the fuck do I...
Do like...
The shape.
I can't.
And then Longoon.
Longoon!
Oh my gosh!
I'm sorry.
My god, it's like...
Okay, maybe...
Okay.
The little R's.
The little...
It's so good.
Oh my god.
I love the little R's.
Alright.
The arms.
It's so good.
And the 60 eyes on this one.
I think that's why it's been bothering me for the longest time.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
The long goons arms are so funny.
Oh my god.
I can't fucking...
I hate this.
I'm trying to do the eyes.
Alright.
That's so...
Sorry.
Alright.
And then the chon...
I'm thinking about like chonky goon.
The chonky goon is like...
No legs.
Why is the chonky goon is just...
It's just no legs.
It's just...
Alright.
The chonky goon is just...
I'm trying to think how the chonky goon would look like.
Is it just that?
Just the head?
Okay.
Okay you guys.
Evolution didn't do you so well.
You don't even have legs or arms.
You're just...
You're just a head.
You don't even have legs or arms.
Or maybe I could do like...
Just like... tiny...
Tiny head... no, just that.
You're just a head.
I love... I'm sorry, Longoon...
I love Longoon the most!
Oh my god!
Hello.
Wait!
Wait a minute!
Wait, okay, but wait...
Wait a minute.
Okay, okay, guys.
Okay.
Should this be Chonky Goon?
Why did we just do all head?
I can't tell.
The missing link.
I can't tell if we should have this...
Or...
Wait, what if this is the normal form?
We could have this as the normal...
I can't tell!
That's...
Make that...
Yeah, this...
What is the base?
This should...
I don't...
I don't know if this is the base design.
I can't tell!
It's so good!
The stick...
The stick legs...
Were...
Were just all head.
It just goes back.
The twig legs are so good though!
Oh yeah, I forgot the horns for each too.
No, the Longu didn't have horns.
Longu never had horns.
It was...
Only...
Uh...
Stick legs with no horns.
We're never gonna win wars!
I can't...
I can't tell!
I can't tell if I want you guys to...
I don't...
If I want you guys to be all head...
Or...
Or like...
With the little legs...
Because it's so funny.
It's so funny.
Bro...
Both legs that help hold up the chunk.
It's like...
I stand up.
You know like those memes where it's like...
Oh, he's...
He's so fucking weak.
And then...
And he gets up.
It's like...
What'd you say?
And then...
He's like...
What'd you say?
He's not gonna catch me.
He has no legs!
And then he just stands up and he's like...
Say it to my face!
They look like...
Nesticles.
How would the plush work?
It's like...
A tiny line.
It's like a tiny...
Legs are...
Okay.
All right.
Chonky goons.
You have a secret power.
We're like...
Your legs are retractable.
Okay?
Okay.
Not gonna lie.
I sort of want this to be the base form now.
Wait.
I can't.
I feel like this as the base form is so good.
So good.
Guys, I feel like this should be the original form.
Okay.
Bye.
I just think... I think this should... guys, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for this guy.
But... this guy is so funny.
Okay, this is gonna be the origin.
Oh my god.
I don't even think you... you know what?
You guys don't need horns.
I feel like no horns is fine.
You just gotta tail.
I feel like... I don't know.
Looking at it... I think it just looks so good like this.
It's just so... bring back my leg, boy.
Alright.
Here is... the long goon.
Long goon, you have real legs.
You have real legs.
And then... honestly, I like the first one.
Alright, how about we make that one the chonk goons.
Oh, but this one is the chonk goon.
Makes more sense.
Oh my god.
That's why he has legs!
Okay, chonk goons.
Base form, no horns.
Cause you guys evolved out of the horns.
So, this is the base.
We're gonna redo all this.
This is...
This is... base form... chonk... long.
This is the evil level 1 versus...
And then...
So, you can draw the base form with no legs.
If you want.
This can... so you can draw a base with no legs or arms.
So, base form has no horns.
He has no horns.
He has evolved out of horns.
Just like the long one.
Just like the long boy.
Chonk... the chonk one.
The chonky guy.
He's still going through evolution right now.
He's still going through evolution.
And then...
And then, obviously...
There's the eggs.
Eggs still exist.
The eggs still exist.
It's just you have different legs now.
And now you have weak ass legs.
I'm gonna have to do my own...
Alright!
Alright, let me draw this a little better.
Let me draw this.
I love this guy.
I love this guy so much.
Oh my god.
We're still the fresh eggs.
He's so funny.
He's just so fucking funny.
Alright, let me...
Let me do a better...
A better line art.
Okay.
Alright.
Let me...
I can't.
There's so...
Little...
Dead eyes.
Oh my god.
When he like fucking stands up.
And was like, what do you say?
What do you say?
Oh my god.
Let me...
Badden this guy up.
Alright.
The death stare.
I mean he can...
You can do different st...
Eyes.
You can do this eye.
Two.
So there's different eyes you can do.
The non I'm gonna kill you.
Ha ha ha ha.
Okay.
You guys have two different eyes.
The I'm not gonna fucking kill you one.
And then the I've seen some stuff.
I've seen things.
So...
There's two sets of eyes.
Guys... I've seen things and I'm not gonna... I'm okay now.
And I'm okay.
But this will be default.
Just in case, this is gonna be default.
I just love the fucking...
I just love the legs.
Alright, base.
The base one.
And then...
The giant one.
Or maybe this can have dot eyes.
No, we'll do... okay.
And then... the giant one here.
The head empty inside.
And then here's the other one.
And then he's like...
And then...
And let me draw this chonky ass...
This chonky ass form.
He's like...
Big.
He's a big boy.
And he has the horns cause he's taking a little bit...
He's taking a little bit to evolve.
Taking a little bit to evolve right now.
Sorry, it's incredibly sketchy.
Cause...
I'm not ready to really art today.
It's so...
It's a little bit very... It's very sketchy.
But I'm pretty sure somebody will be able to draw this better than me.
Alright.
But I'm giving you guys the base design right now.
And then... his legs.
His little legs.
That credit here to...
To Tinn for doing...
For giving this concept and making me go like...
Whoa!
Really like it.
I really like the concept.
I wonder if I should give you guys a now.
And then...
That's the chonky go.
I feel like he should be...
Maybe like...
Round.
Okay.
But...
What if...
What if... what if guys... he's like... this big... you know?
He's like...
big...
But like what if he's like... huge... okay?
He needs to run...
I feel like I can adjust his chonkiness a little bit more.
Give me a sec.
I feel like I can adjust the chonkiness.
Just a little bit more.
I feel like it's possible.
I feel like I can do... make him like more egg shape.
Oh yes!
YES!
Oh yeah, there we go.
I just need it to be... I just want it to be wider.
There we go.
Oh maybe it's like a little bit too wide.
Let me just... maybe it's a little bit too wide.
There we go.
Middle.
I think we can settle with the middle wide.
There we go.
Because he has to be chonk!
You know?
He's chonky.
He's a wide goon.
And then... long goon time.
Long goon has evolved away from... has always never had horns.
So... he's fine.
They've always been fine.
So...
And then...
And then... boop!
Yep.
And then...
There we go.
And then finally!
Finally!
Egg.
Now you don't have spots anymore.
Because birds don't have spots on their...
On their eggs.
I mean some birds.
This... this bird doesn't.
Maybe... actually... I don't know.
No.
No spots.
Because you're not... you're not dinosaurs anymore.
You're an egg.
It's just... it's just a white egg.
It's just a white egg.
Oh cracks in the... no I think... if you want cracks, that's your own egg.
That's your own egg.
Alright.
So there's the base design.
Obviously you can draw the base design as just a head.
Because you were just born like that.
You can either be a headless... headless version or the stick one.
When you're just sitting down.
So like when you're sitting down, you guys have no legs, you know?
And then it's like you retract it.
You like extract it.
Hahahaha.
When you sit down, you look like this.
And then when I'll be like, alright dragons, come over here.
You go like, huh?
Hahahaha.
You're like, huh?
So...
So when you're like, oh my god, Doki's calling for me.
Okay, normally... normally... it's like either no legs...
And you're just like... you're just a head.
This is static.
Standby mode.
Standby mode versus not standby mode.
Go catch it, Kun.
Okay.
Stand by...
Legs.
Hahahaha.
So...
Um...
So like...
That is the... that is the evolution line.
Energy saving.
Yeah, yeah.
So this is the base form.
This is regular... regular mode of dragoons.
And then... and then this is Chonky Goon, where you guys have not really evolved quite so far.
Hahahaha.
You guys haven't really evolved so far.
So you're still just a little bit...
Little bit behind in the...
The evolution line.
And then...
And then there's the long goons.
Where you're still long.
And the Tokimons.
And then the...
And then the egg goons are still there.
They're still there.
Alright.
I like this idea.
Alright, anyway.
Anyway, let's me color this real quick.
So...
Alright, so the colors are gonna be pretty easy.
It's gonna be...
We're not gonna have cheek dots at all.
So...
It's gonna be yellow.
Here.
This is gonna be so fucking rough.
I swear it looks so much better.
I'll do...
I'll like recolor all...
I'll redraw this a little bit better.
I swear.
But these are the colors.
I like the colors in the background.
I like the colors that this artist chose.
Because I think it's really cute.
I always like the little pastel.
I mean, I could make it a little bit lighter.
Maybe.
No.
Actually, I like this yellow.
And then...
Here's like...
I don't know if I want the little belly now.
I feel like it looks better with no belly.
Oh my god.
But yes.
Like previous Evolution line.
You can...
You don't have to be yellow.
You guys don't have to be yellow.
You can be different colors if you really want to.
So you can be a...
A green...
A green goon.
But like yellow is the default.
No belly or belly?
I can't tell if I want a belly or not.
I can't tell yet.
Honestly.
Keep the belly.
Or maybe we can use like white instead.
Maybe.
Maybe white would look better than the...
Pale yellow.
But it's true pale.
Maybe...
I don't know if I want the belly or not.
Can't tell yet.
I need to see.
Maybe if I put the belly like this.
Maybe it'll look better.
I can't tell.
I can't tell if I want the belly or not.
Let's see.
Belly or no belly.
Belly.
So hard to pick.
I'm so indecisive.
Yes belly?
Belly good?
Okay, we'll keep the belly.
All right, if you guys think belly good we'll keep it.
Let me see...
Alright, and then...
Just gonna give you guys the beak and stuff.
Beaks are always orange, just so you guys know.
It's always orange.
And then...
Like...
It looks like this.
There you go.
This looks like fucking Big Bird.
I just realized...
I just realized he looks like fucking Big Bird.
Oh my god.
We're in Sesame Street right now.
Alright, so this one looks like Belly and Noble.
I guess...
There you go.
Or maybe a tinier Belly, I don't know.
Alright.
This is the official designs.
The official Dragoons.
Big Bird-y balloons.
You guys can clearly draw this a lot better than what I did.
My friendly neighborhood.
Look at that!
Longoon evolved into having legs!
Congratulations!
Longoon.
You now have legs!
I mean you had... I mean arms, sorry.
You now have arms!
Congratulations!
Longoon.
You have arms now!
Let's give a warm welcome to the official Dragoon evolution line.
This is honestly my favorite because of the legs activation.
I love the legs activation.
You can grab now!
You can grab things!
Congratulations!
Oh my god!
I'm so proud of all of you.
I'm...
Incredibly proud of all of you.
Anyway.
So...
Egg...
We all start off as eggs.
Then, we go here.
And then, these guys are like awkward in between cousins.
And the awkward...
The awkward cousins of the bunch.
Wouldn't it be funny though if like, okay this is a little dumb, but like you would think that...
You would think the chonky guy is like the biggest one, but like what if they're like...
What if like the chonky guys are like this size?
They're chonky but small.
Anyway, no, I think like all size... actually I feel like maybe chonky goon would be like this.
Because like, you know, when you're evolving... when you're evolving you get...
Okay, so like my logic here is that, you know, like dinosaurs they evolve smaller and smaller.
But like...
The chonky goons, you know, because they're going into...
They're like birds, right?
So they're still big, you know?
They're still big!
So we're gonna go by that logic.
So next to like...
Next to them they're like double their size, you know?
It's just like... just like evolution.
Their chonky goons are bigger than the base size.
The base goons are...
They're small.
They be...
So yeah.
There's not much going on in the chonky goons head.
Just so you guys know.
If you guys are like, I'm a chonky goon!
Lore wise!
There's much not...
There's not a lot going on.
And the horns are like sort of like poking into their brains right now.
So they're still a little bit...
They're still...
They're still getting there.
You know?
They're...
They're getting there.
So...
So you know, just like cavemen, you know?
Like the cavemen they are.
Like...
Base form goon is...
Is like the 2020s right now.
Base goons are 2020s.
And then chonky goon is still 500 BC.
So...
Base goon is like the future.
Who we strive to be.
Long and have...
And a bit thick.
Long and a bit thick.
I was thinking if the...
No, I feel like...
I think like...
I don't know if we should have like legs for the...
Someone was like, what about the stick legs for eggs?
Alright, let me see.
The stick legs.
What would stick legs look like?
No.
No!
Wait, actually...
Okay, do we give the eggs stick legs?
Or...
Guys...
Do we...
Do we give them real legs?
Or stick legs?
Like...
Do we...
What do you guys want?
The stick legs?
Or the...
Or real legs?
Okay, you guys get stick legs.
Because you're from the base form.
Alright, there we go.
This is the evolution line.
We've all...
We've all like grew as...
Grew...
We all grew, guys.
All of us have evolved.
We are all birds now.
We're all birds now.
Looks scuffed but lower I guess.
Alright, here we go.
Here's the lore.
You have been named.
You have all been officially named.
And given a vision of what you all look like.
I hope you guys are happy with your new form.
I love the little stick legs.
Me too.
It's so fucking stupid.
I love it.
You can be any color for the birds.
You can be any different types of color if you want.
But yellow is the default because I'm yellow.
Yellow is the default.
But you can be any different colors.
Reject evolution, remain a dinosaur.
LordCroesus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Nesticles, let's go!
We're not nesticles!
We're dragoons!
I mean, if you want pants, you can have pants.
Like, I'm not going to like... I'm not going to say no.
It's your vision.
Anyway, huge shoutout to Tin for the concept.
I might be lazy and I might...
Tin!
If you're watching this right now...
I might commission you to do this.
To make a better reference sheet of this.
Because this is just me fucking sketching it out.
And I feel like it's so dirty right now.
It's so rough.
I feel like Tin will do a better job and put much more effort.
And I should repay you for such a neat concept.
I really did like the concept that they did.
What will happen if Long Agoon is just a nesticle?
I wonder what it would be like if it just has no arms.
Oh no, that looks so bad.
Long Agoon needs arms.
Alright!
This is it.
This is the evolution line.
Size-wise, Chonky Agoon is much bigger.
It's bigger than Base...
Base Goons.
Default Goons.
The Chonky Goon is...
GINORMOUS compared to the Default Goons.
And then Long Goons is like...
Just long.
The body is very similar to the Default Goon.
He just has a very long neck.
That's really it.
And then there's Agoon with his fucking stick legs.
Alright!
I think we did it!
We named it!
We named and gave you guys a form!
Oh my god.
This should have been done on like day 2.
But like...
There should have been a lot of things done.
But I did my best!
Alright.
I...
I hope you guys liked the little naming ceremony for all of you.
And also for the naming ceremony and your true form.
Your true form.
My little dragoons.
My little dragoons that are now...
That are based off of a military unit by the way.
Just so you all know.
It's all based off of my love for Starcraft and military units.
But now you're now full birds.
Now you have evolved into little birds.
But yeah!
Anyway!
That was fun!
I hope you guys had a lot of fun.
I had a fun time hanging out with all of you.
I'll be posting my schedule either tonight or tomorrow.
Monday.
Tomorrow there will be no stream.
No stream on Sunday.
So yeah.
Most likely I'll post the schedule tomorrow or tonight.
So we'll see how it goes.
We'll see how it goes.
I hope you guys have a great Lunar New Year.
Can't wait to have my dinner with my family.
And I want to say again...
恭喜發財大家大禮身體健康!
To everybody!
Happy Lunar New Year everyone!
I hope you guys have a really fun time with your family and friends.
Or with me!
Because I'm your family now!
You guys have a fun time celebrating with me guys.
I'm going to call it over here.
But thank you everybody for joining the membership.
I really appreciate it everybody for joining the membership.
All the gifted ships.
And all the super chats today.
All the akas, yellows, magentas, and insert other colors.
I hope you guys have a fun time hanging out.
I'm going to call it here.
As always everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everyone.
Bye guys!
Bye!